Esta es la segunda vez que el gobernador
de Texas manda buses llenos de
inmigrantes a la casa de la
vicepresidenta kamala Harris en una
semana ya son
inmigrantes indocumentados que cruzaron
la frontera de Estados Unidos que son
enviados a Washington estas sin contar
la cantidad de inmigrantes que están
siendo enviados a Nueva York a Chicago y
a otras ciudades del norte de Norte
liberal lo que muchos critican es que
precisamente Greg abbott gobernador de
Texas y John de Santi ron de santis
gobernador de la Florida Pues están
usando esta estrategia porque les está
dando crédito sobre todo a nivel
mediático esto de Cara a las elecciones
legislativas y de Cara a que ellos están
también pues concursando para su
reelección como gobernadores los
inmigrantes muchos de ellos venezolanos
demandaron precisamente a ron de Santi
por aprovecharse políticamente de esto y
lo llamaron como un fraude algo que pues
no cayó nada bien en la Florida en la
gobernación de la Florida diciendo que
los demócratas estaban aprovechandose de
la situación de los migrantes Para
demandar a gobiernos republicanos hay
que Resaltar que las calles de
Washington empiezan ya a ver a estos
migrantes caminar por las ciudades y
cuando se les pregunta qué es lo que
buscan donde quieren parar ellos
responden que lo único que están
buscando en realidad es empleo y
Cristóbal por otro lado acaba de
anunciarse hace poco que el presidente
vaiden perdonará a todos los condenados
a nivel Federal Federal por posesión de
marihuana Cómo llevará a cabo byden este
proceso y cuáles son las razones que se
escriben
sí le está pidiendo entonces a los
gobernadores que en a nivel a nivel
Estatal implementen esta medida también
en este momento el perdón es solamente
para aquellos que están condenados a
crímenes federales y los que Argumenta
el presidente Joey es que estas personas
al hacer condenadas y al estar Pues
incriminadas de estos delitos pues no
tienen acceso ni a vivienda ni educación
ni empleo y que entonces quitar esta
Barrera pues va a ser que estas personas
puedan Buscar una vida un poco más
normal y tener más oportunidades para
llegar a esto además va a afectar
obviamente a las cárceles privadas que
son la mayoría acá en Estados Unidos y a
Pues precisamente a estas cárceles
Porque muchos críticos dicen y se revela
a partir de los datos que entregan estas
cárceles que la mayoría de estas
personas encarceladas por estos delitos
menores son afroamericanos y latinos así
que pues es una promesa de campaña que
está cumpliendo el presidente biden con
este anuncio